I'm at Madaba Dean and this series is
about how technology changes people for
better and for worse
i investigate facial recognition at the
border meet men struggling with
addiction at a gaming rehab learn about
the harassment women face online do
interviews with current and former
Facebook employees and travel to
Macedonia to better understand fake news
[Music]
[Applause]
you refer to yourself as the man who
accidentally helped Donald Trump win the
u.s. election do you think games are
designed to be addictive yeah you didn't
even hesitate so how does the company
fix this I don't know I don't think
Facebook knows the answer to it either
when big tech break things and ask
questions later it affects everyone
now I'm looking into what got broken and
how to fix it
[Applause]
[Music]